the problem is people start to get  entitled because they feel like like  exactly what happened in that situation  so if I'm hiring five people and I know  this guy's the most productive right and  I know he deserves more money or she  whoever it is and let's say I paid them  75 000 a year in a high pay someone else  50. when when they find out about the  Gap the other person might feel like  they're just disqualified and they might  feel like they do just as much work but  I'm the bot like I'm the boss I see I  see who actually does the most work and  that's why you can't have paid  transparency because you have people  that feel like they're worth more than  they are